if you want to know how the g20 summit
went for joe biden well this photo says
it all
not only was joe the last to arrive for
the group photo he's positioned way out
in left field playing where's waldo with
world leaders the opposite of donald
trump who was front and center for these
pictures every single time trump's sole
mission was putting america first and
exhibiting strength on the world stage
when trump was in charge he didn't let
anyone push us around instead he did all
the pushing like the time he shoved the
prime minister of montenegro during a
tour of the nato headquarters in 2017.
we know joe biden couldn't do that he's
the pushover here his credibility is
weak and now that trump is gone
these countries are walking all over us
joining me now nationally syndicated
radio host and author dana lash welcome
dana it's so great to have you on thanks
so much thanks rachel good to be with
you so sometimes a picture says a
thousand words i mean there was joe
biden way off to the end i think he was
next to the president of congo um what
does this tell you about
joe biden and whether he's putting our
country first
oh goodness this photo it's so awkward
because you're right he's standing just
over to the side he's like the odd man
out like it's a group of friends that
got together you know maybe they had
like a backyard barbecue they're all
posing for a photo and joe's like the
guest of someone who really doesn't know
anyone else there it's weird and and it
just seemed weak like his address to his
address to the summit seemed weak the
week the whole thing was weak now i
remember rachel and you were just
talking about this all of the headlines
about former president trump who really
kind of like pushed his way through to
the front and center where by the way
america should be because not a single
one of these objectives that are all
dearly held by every single one of these
leaders present and pictured are even in
anywhere in the realm of being
accomplished were it not for the
participation of the united states if
there's a country that has a problem
they treat them they treat the united
states like we're like ghostbusters or
something are you going to call america
we're going to call the united states to
come and get us out of every single jam
so yes and america by the way because
the last day the last uh the topic for
the last day of discussions as i
understand it was about climate rachel
so the united states so me talking about
the paris agreement is the only country
that's present and party to this that
actually reduced emissions that that's
the thing that people are going for so
yeah joe biden should have pushed his
way right to the front and center and if
people don't like it they can step up
and do as much as america does for the
rest of the world absolutely it's so you
know they're going as our country is
facing inflation all kinds of economic
issues you know they're he's there
actually trying to figure out ways to
make gas and energy more expensive for
us uh you know and also with with donald
trump you bring up such a great point
you know when he went it wasn't just the
photo op he always came back with like
they're going to pay more money for the
help that we're giving or the security
that we're giving them he was actually
looking out for american people i look
at joe biden he's figuring out ways for
us to pay more
yeah i know trump would get trump would
get concessions he would get an
agreement that's why he and angela
merkel one of the reasons why they went
round and round everybody remembers that
one picture where trump was sitting at
the desk and merkel was kind of hanging
point pointing a finger at him kind of
looking angrily at him well one of the
reasons why that conversation why there
was a little bit of tension there is
because trump was insisting that germany
pay into as much to nato as the united
states does it's for your own defense
against that against that common um you
know political enemy so yeah trump would
come out with some concessions and
people did not like him because he did
not take the flak whereas biden is
apologizing for
us leaving the paris agreement which was
essentially an unconstitutional treaty
binding every of the 50 states so it's
insane so yeah he should have been front
and center but he's too weak somebody
should have let him there
well listen there were f 400 private
jets that went to the g12 summit where
they talked about climate um and and
then joe biden had an 85 car motorcade
to go visit the pope where they also
discussed the weather how grotesque is
all this
it's it's hypocrisy i'm not going to be
lectured to nor should you or anyone
watching this right now we should not be
lectured to by people who don't even
follow their own advice people who
behave like this this whole i get it
there's not there's not a consensus on
it they're acting like this is it's like
a rich person's hobby like get crochet
like somebody like a normal person this
is insane it's sickening i couldn't
agree and i don't know how to crochet
it's a good one all right dana thanks so
much for joining us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else